>>commentator: Tonight's speaker is Professor
Ruut Veenhoven who's the Emeritus Professor
of Social Conditions for Human Happiness at
the Erasmus University of Rotterdam, which
he reminded me tonight is also the university
from where Commissioner Cruz comes from.
[applause]
>> Professor Rutt Veenhoven: Well great.
Let's start with the question what happiness
is. That's the most difficult one.
Once we establish that we can assess how happy
we are and grasp at what makes us happy. And
then even can give an evidence-based answer
on whether we can get happier than we are.
Well and if we can get happier, what can policymakers
do about that? Do we have a special role next
to the psychiatrist?
So happiness; one word; many meanings.
And if we use happiness in this context, it's
typically related to quality of life, which
is another word with also many meanings. And
when we speak about quality of life, we typically
-- we can think of chances for a good life
and the outcomes of life. And you can be born
in a nice loving family, good chances and
that was a direct problem that outcomes.
There are qualities in your environment; there
are qualities in yourself; and that gives
us four qualities of life which all have been
named happiness at some point. But I give
them other names: chances in the environment,
that's the livability of the environment;
chances in yourself; that's your life-ability.
So the best possible life-ability is in heaven,
but some people are so neurotic, so low ability
that even in heaven they would be displeased
and quarrel with the angels.
When turning to the outcomes of life, you
can say, "Well what is a good life?" Well
if you judge that on the contribution of your
life through the environment that is the utility
of your life, which is not the same as your
satisfaction with life.
You can have a very useful life. For instance,
Florence Nightingale had a very useful life,
but we know from her biography that she was
not very satisfied. Actually she was a bit
depressed.
Well, policymakers typically focus on this;
this is their business. And so people want
to improve society and define quality of life
this way. People who want to improve your
abilities, your teacher and your psychologist,
they define quality of life and happiness
in this way.
And well, if you ask your priest, "Father
what is a good life?" Then the priest will
probably say, "Well, what you do in God's
garden." And if you have a real priest, they
say, "Well and it's even better if you don't
have satisfaction." [laughs]
[laughter]
And here you see a problem. All of these meanings
are backed by institutional interests and
this is not. But you see I underlined it.
If I speak about happiness I speak about happiness
in the sense of life of satisfaction; which
begs another question because there are different
kinds of satisfaction.
There's partial satisfaction, satisfaction
with life as a whole, and passing and enduring,
which give these four which also have been
named happiness.
And there is the partial passing pleasure:
the glass of wine, the sensoric pleasure.
And this lecture, I hope, intellectual pleasure.
[laughs]
[laughter]
But it's passing. [laughs]
There's also partial domain satisfaction:
satisfaction with your job; satisfaction with
your country, which is not the same as life
satisfaction. And some people are very satisfied
with their job; and work all weekends; then
discover some day that the spouse has gone
and they're still very satisfied with their
job, but not with their life.
Here we have another thing called happiness.
When poets talk about happiness, they typically
talk about that one sublime moment where they
had an oceanic feeling.
And there is passing experience of life as
a whole, also called happiness, but not the
same as life satisfaction. And actually there's
a negative relationship.
People who experience these talks, are open
for these talks, are typically not the ones
who enjoy life as a whole.
You see I underlined it. If I speak about
happiness, I speak about happiness in the
sense of life satisfaction, enduring satisfaction
with life as a whole.
It appears also from research that happiness
is beneficial. Happy people are more active;
they are more sociable; they are even better
citizens in political sense. They pay their
taxes more, they read the newspapers more,
they vote more, they don't drive fast.
[laughter]
And what is behind, and well, the most interesting
thing is that they live longer. And they really
live longer. The effect of being happy or
not on how long you live is comparable to
smoking or not. Why is that? Well, basically
it is because if you feel happy that is because
your needs are gratified and it means that
as an organism biologically you're [trifling].
And well [trifle] organisms tend to be healthier
and then to be more active.
And then in the case of the health effects,
which is mostly in that there is a lower chance
that you fall ill. If you're chronically unhappy
that triggers the fight/flight system, and
well if that takes years, then you're more
susceptible for flu. And that's why unhappy
people die earlier.
And so in that respect I would say that happiness
fits most of the things we want anyway. We
want good health, we want participation, and
it's not an alien political goal.
Well that kind of happiness is something we
have in mind.
[pause]
And that's something you can simply ask.
And you can do it with simple questions such
as this one: "Taking all together, how satisfied
or dissatisfied are you with your life as
a whole these days?" Always have a time reference.
And well, if you are very dissatisfied you
say 1, if you're very satisfied, you say 10.
[pause]
It's a very simple question, and the beautiful
thing is that it's so simple that everybody
understands.
In surveys, there is less than one percent
who say "don't know." So most people answer
this question and they answer it instantly
which means that's actually something that
is on their mind.
[pause]
And if you use this question in well a general
population survey, you see for instance in
Switzerland --
[pause]
this;
twenty five percent 10, 9, 8;
[pause]
well most people in Switzerland are very satisfied
with their life. Not everybody is. There are
also 4 and even people who score 1, but it's
a minority.
And when my colleagues, sociologists, who
earn their living in social problems when
they see this they are displeased. And they
don't believe.
[laughter]
And they say, "Well there's social durability."
And the [Marxists] say it's false consciousness."
[laughs]
But then I show another picture. The same
question, the same time, another country.
[pause]
Here we have Zimbabwe.
Thirty percent scoring 1.
[pause]
Most people below 5.
And yes, there are a few very happy persons,
possibly you can imagine someone --
[laughter]
And here we are talking about the people who
are still in Zimbabwe, [laughs] because a
quarter has already left the country because
it's so miserable.
And so you see there is quite a difference.
[pause]
And well, using these distributions, you can
compute an average from 0 to 1, and we have
that here on these magnificent Google Maps.
[laughter]
Even more beautiful than I have it here.
So you always wanted to know how happy people
were in Kazakhstan --
[laughter]
Well 6.1.
In Africa, so the lighter the color, the less
happy. So here is Zimbabwe and here is Iceland,
data from before the crisis.
[laughter]
But surprise, surprise, the data after crisis
are hardly different. They dropped from 8.2
to 8. This correlates with another finding
that in rich countries you can live with economic
recessions. And we can live with the illnesses
of capitalism.
[pause]
Okay, once you know to what extent people
differ, you can try to get a look at the determinants.
In thinking about the determinants, this scheme
which I showed you, this conceptual scheme,
makes sense because you can say, "Well how
happy people are will depend on the livability
of their environment and also on their life-ability."
And in doing so, you think actually the way
biologists think about survival.
Because biologists, if they want to know whether
a species survives, they say, "Well there
must be a suitable biotope, but the animal
should also fit." And they use the term "fitness"
rather than "life-ability."
And in using the term "fitness" they say,
"Well you can be very able, but it should
be functional in the biotope."
Hey if a frog can play the violin, which is
a remarkable achievement, but it's hardly
any use. [laughs]
[laughter]
So our problem here is when we study life-abilities,
is to see which abilities are not only beautiful
and a piece of civilization, but are also
actually functional in present day society.
Well, if we follow this scheme it's difficult,
as yet, to get it to fit. But we can make
at least correlations between aspects of livability
and aspects of life-ability. And if we look
at the kind of society where policymakers
head -- that's their main business -- then,
for instance, you can say, "Well is there
a correlation between happiness and the differences
we see here and happiness?"
But we already see African nations are unhappy
and we know they are poor.
But here you see a more systematic picture.
And here are these African nations; here is
Denmark;
[pause]
well here is Luxemburg, but that's black money
[laughs]
[laughter]
doesn't really count. This is oil money [laughs].
There's also oil money.
But actually you see that there is a pretty
linear relationship. The only exception here
is Latin America which you see here that the
Latin Americans are happier and they are,
actually some of them are happier than the
U.S.
[pause]
And that's something you can't explain by
their wealth, because they're pretty happy
but not too wealthy.
Let's look at not the amount of wealth, but
at the distribution of wealth in countries.
And so now we are looking at income inequality.
What do you see? No correlation, yes.
[laughter]
And this is another thing that my colleagues
find hard to believe. [laughs]
Actually I had a problem believing it myself
in the beginning. I thought I had made a mistake
so I recalculated it; I used other indicators,
but I kept on finding the same thing.
There is no correlation, which doesn't say
that income inequality doesn't affect happiness
at all. But it probably means that it affects
happiness both positively and negatively.
[pause]
And so that in the end the effects balance
out.
[pause]
Another thing that is quality of governments
and I think that is something that appeals
to you. And well here you see, here are the
African nations, miserable and very bad government.
I use here the World Bank measurement of government
effectiveness, which is actually the technical
quality of government and not so much the
democratic, but just is there a smooth bureaucracy,
is it responsive, is it not corrupt?
And you see there is a very strong relationship.
[pause]
Well, then you can compute correlations and
then you see that good governance is up on
top, but very closely economic affluence and
democracy; gender equality; yes, that's positively
correlated, but income equality not.
And here in this graph you see a positive
effect with state welfare, but that disappears
once you control economic wealth.
[pause]
And this explains three-quarters of the huge
differences in happiness around the world
which you see here.
[pause]
So we are pretty close in understanding why
these things differ.
[pause]
There is what's the livability, but now the
life-ability. And now actually we move to
that first diagram of Switzerland. And now
the question is: why are people within a country
not equally happy? Why score some people in
Switzerland 10, but others 7 or even 1?
And to make a very long story short, in modern
societies such as Switzerland, these differences
which you have seen are about 30 percent – it's
genetic.
[pause]
Which doesn't say that the happiness as such
is genetic, but that things that predispose
to the abilities required for getting happy
are genetic; part is physical health, a big
part is mental health.
[pause]
Even in countries like Switzerland, you can
have good or bad luck. And so in such countries
good or bad luck explains 10 percent. In Zimbabwe
it's probably 40 percent.
[pause]
Social position, the concern of my colleagues,
sociologists, is actually very small. And
social economic position, how much money you
have, how high you are on the social ladder,
explains less than five percent; most is in
social networks.
[pause]
Now this is what we know fairly well.
Here are my guesses.
[pause]
I guess, but I don't really know, because
it's difficult to measure, that, well, part
is in learned abilities.
[pause]
And because we live in a multiple choice society,
I think that also part is in choice.
[pause]
And we are happy in these countries actually;
this whole Western world. But in that situation,
your happiness depends on whether you make
the right choices; have the partner that really
fits you and not the partner that fits the
preference of your mother,
[laughter]
which a problem in Japan.
Now to the question: is greater happiness
possible?
And then there are a lot of theorists who
say, "No, that's not possible."
But now we can test these theories.
One theory is a favorite theory by psychologists,
most of which are in the business of measuring
traits, and they say everything is a trait
and happiness is also a trait. And, genetically,
you're more or less predisposed to be so happy.
And in the first year, if your mother mistreats
you, too bad -- you will be unhappy for the
rest of your life.
[pause]
So according to this theory, even if you create
a better society, everybody will remain as
depressed as they were before.
Another theory, and quite common among economists,
is that happiness is a matter of comparison.
And that you are happier if you are doing
better than the Jones'. And according to this
theory, you can make people happy by depraving
the Jones'.
[pause]
Comparison theory; and according to this theory
there is no sense and this is also the hedonic
treadmill theory.
But there's also a theory that says, "Well,
humans have innate needs. We want food, we
want sex, we are social animals. We want contacts
and like all animals, we also have an innate
need to use our potentials." Some people call
that the need for self-actualization.
And according to that theory, well, if a society
fits these human needs, then they are happier;
actually also live longer.
Well that's the theories. What are the facts?
[pause]
Well the facts are, first of all, that some
countries are much happier than the others.
Still you could say, "Well Russian unhappiness,
its Russian genes or at least that they drink
too much vodka. But you see even Russian happiness
is not a stable cultural trait because they
got much less happy during the ruble crisis
and they're now recovering pretty well.
[pause]
And, actually, if we look in Europe other
countries and we compare the first Euro barometer
then with the one in 2006, then we see that
the Italians gained about one full point.
Okay, they started pretty low [laughs]
[laughter]
but still there's no immutable trait. And
even the Danes who are the champion, they
are the happiest country in the world, but
they still in the last 38 years gained half
a point. And Belgium is a strange thing.
[laughter]
I think someone has messed up the data. [laughs]
>>male in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Professor Ruut Veehoven: Yeah. Well actually
Flemish in Flanders is happier than Valognes
and that is typical in the whole European
pattern. From north to south, happiness sinks.
Sun rises, happiness sinks.
[laughter]
Okay, so it's possible to get happier than
we are. And what can policy makers do?
[pause]
Well, they can improve the livability of the
environment which is their prime job, but
they could also improve the life-ability of
individuals at least indirectly. If we do
it this way then you can focus on society
as a whole, but you can also focus on institutions
in societies.
Let's first look at society as a whole. And
well, what we have seen that you should invest
in good governance, democracy, and gender
equality because that are the strong predictors,
and not in income equality. Too bad for the
Socialists and even the welfare state doesn't
really add. Which is not to say that income
inequality is not unfair and so, for other
reasons, you can say, "Well I want to reduce
income inequality" and because it doesn't
hurt happiness, I can do my ideal." But if
you focus on happiness in the first place,
you should seek it here. And I guess nobody
is against good governance.
[pause]
But what you can also do is focus on more
livable institutions and I'll take the example
of care homes.
[pause]
Because what is the product of a care home?
Well, that is few happy life years. If you
look for a good care home for your dementing
mother, what do you see? Well you see a nice
building, you are received, you have nice
prints and advertisements, but you don't really
know how long and happy the people live there.
The quality assessment of these kind of institutions
is very much dictated by professional interests:
so how well the staff is paid; how many hands
there are on the bed; whether the right procedures
are followed; but not how the patients feel.
[pause]
And because there is no measurement of that,
there's no competition. And competition is
rather on the marketing rather than on the
product. Well and I think that is something
that politicians can change. And that they
can create, well, more visibility in the market.
And that's not only the case with care homes,
but that's also the case with schools.
[pause]
If you look for a good school for your children
you also would like to know whether they have
a good time there and whether they learn also
the abilities that will give them a happier
life later.
So I think if politicians press for happiness
monitoring, this will enable citizens to make
more informed choices. I would say if you
would strengthen the life-ability of individuals;
invest in preventive mental health care.
I've just done a study and looked at the size
of the mental health budget in the health
budget, and I found a sizeable correlation.
So this really works.
Another option is invest in professional life-coaching.
And lastly this is a project where I am involved
-- is support life choices.
We do a large scale follow up study which
now covers 30,000 people on the Internet.
We follow how happy they are and we follow
what happens when they make choices. For instance,
having a child or taking earlier retirement
--
[pause]
or moving to Brussels.
And what we want to see in the long run, and
it will take about 10 years, is what kind
of people get happier from having a child
and what kind not. We know that most people
get less happy when they get children. You
lose about half a point. [laughs]
[laughter]
But that's the average.
You would like to know how it works out for
people like you. What is your risk?
Likewise, some people who take early retirement
get depressed; other people who flourish.
For the case of greater happiness, you shouldn't
invest in schooling because there is no correlation
with level of education. Actually university
educated people tend to be slightly less happy.
[laughs] And also not a correlation at all
with I.Q.
[pause]
Conclusion. Greater happiness is possible
and it can be achieved at three levels: the
macro level of society, for instance, better
governance; the meso level of organizations;
and the micro level of individuals. And in
each gauge, effect-research is required.
And that's it.
Well most of this wisdom comes from the World
Database of Happiness where I gather well
all scientific research on happiness and present
the findings in an easy or viewable way.
The map you saw is but a part of this World
Database of Happiness.
[applause]